The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
BOGDAN FEDELES: Hello
and welcome to 5.07
Biochemistry online.
I'm Dr. Bogdan Fedeles.
This video is about pyridoxal
5 phosphate, or PLP,
an essential metabolism cofactor
derived from vitamin B6.
All animals are
auxotrophic for PLP,
meaning they need to supplement
their diet with vitamin B6
in order to survive.
PLP is one of the most
ancient cofactors,
and surprisingly,
it can catalyze
chemical transformation,
such as a transamination
even without an enzyme.
PLP is actually involved
in a staggering number
of biochemical transformations.
This video summarizes the most
important reactions involving
PLP that you will see
in 5.07, and will also
show you how to write
the complete curved arrow
mechanisms for these
transformations.
Let's talk about
PLP-catalyzed reactions.
As we just mentioned,
PLP is the cofactor
derived from vitamin B6.
This cofactor is very important
for a number of reactions.
In this course, we're
going to look particularly
at the transamination reaction.
This is a crucial reaction for
the metabolism of all amino
the acids, and we're also going
to encounter this reaction when
we replenish the intermediates
in the TCA cycle, what
we call anaplerotic reactions.
And we're also going to see
PLP involved in reactions
in the malate-aspartate
shuttle that transfers redox
equivalents,
reducing equivalents,
between mitochondria
and cytosol.
Let's take a look at the
structure of vitamin B6, also
known as pyridoxine.
This is the molecule that
we ingest when we get
our daily vitamin supplement.
Now in the body, this
gets oxidized to form
intermediate called pyridoxal.
Notice the aldehyde
group here, which
is going to be the business
end of the molecule.
Now, the active co-factor, PLP--
it's actually the phosphorylated
version of pyridoxal.
This requires one
molecule of ATP
and the enzyme pyridoxal kinase.
And we get PLP, or
pyridoxal 5 phosphate.
The name PLP comes from the
initials as outlined here.
Now, this nitrogen
on the pyridine ring
tends to be protonated
because it's pKa,
it's close to physiological
pH, between 6 and 7.
Now, for the rest
of this presentation
we're going to be abbreviating
this phosphate group as such,
and throughout the course.
Now, a related molecule is
pyridoxamine 5 phosphate,
which we'll see,
it's an intermediate
in the mechanism of
PLP-catalyzed reactions.
Also known as PMP.
Now, notice the PMP
has an amine group here
which replaces the aldehydic
group, which is the business
end of the molecule.
Now, in all reactions
with PLP, this co-factor
is actually covalently bound
to the enzyme that uses it.
Typically, there's a lysine in
the active site of the enzyme.
As you remember, lysine
has an amine group,
and this can form a Schiff
base with the aldehyde.
The reaction proceeds
in two steps.
First, we form a
tetrahedral intermediate.
As such.
And then, we form
the Schiff's base.
So this will be the
enzyme-bound PLP.
And this is where all the
PLP-catalyzed reactions start.
Let's take a closer look at
the transamination reaction.
Transamination reaction
occurs between an amino acid
and an alpha keto acid.
We have here amino acid 1, where
we highlighted the amine group,
and alpha keto acid 2.
As you can see, there's a keto
group next to the carboxyl.
Now, in a transamination
reaction catalyzed by PLP,
the amine group moves
from the amino acid
to the keto carbon of
the alpha keto acid.
And we obtain a new alpha keto
acid, and a new amino acid.
So in effect, the PLP-catalyzed
transamination reaction
facilitates the transfer
of the amine group
from an amino acid to
an alpha keto acid.
Now, this reaction actually
occurs in two steps.
In the first step, the amino
acid transfers the group
to the co-factor itself.
So if you remember from
the previous slide,
the PMP contains an amino
group, and that will actually
contain this amino
group that was
taken from the amino acid 1.
Now in the second step, the PMP
will transfer its amino group
to a different alpha keto acid
to generate a new amino acid.
Now, there are
enzymes for virtually
every single amino acid
that can accomplish
this first transformation,
where by using PLP,
to transfer the amine group
and form an alpha keto
acid and PMP.
Now, in the second
part of the reaction,
however, the alpha keto acid
2 is typically alpha keto
gluterate or oxaloacetate.
So in this case, not any
alpha keto acid can function.
Alpha keto gluterate
or oxaloacetate.
Now, let's take a
look at an example.
For example, glutamate.
It's going to be our amino acid.
And oxaloacetate is going
to be our alpha keto acid.
And in a PLP-catalyzed
transformation,
we will obtain the alpha
keto acid corresponding
to glutamate,
which is alpha keto
glutarate, and the amino acid
corresponding to oxaloacetate,
which is aspartate.
This enzyme that catalyzes
this transformation
is in fact ubiquitous,
and it's found
both in the liver and the
muscles, and it is in fact a--
we can call it, depending
and the product,
we can call it aspartate,
transaminase or glutamate
oxaloacetate transaminase.
In fact, if we find
this in the bloodstream,
this enzyme acts as a biomarker.
And it tells us
about some damage
that might have occurred
in muscle or liver, which
forced the cells to
spill out their contents.
This biomarker is--
you'll often see as SGOT--
serum glutamate
oxaloacetate transaminase.
And this is just one
of the biomarkers that
are measured in blood tests
that tells us about heart
disease or liver disease.
Let's take a look at the
mechanism of the transamination
reaction.
And in particular, we're
going to take a look
at part one, which as
we discussed before,
the amino acid reacts with
PLP to form an alpha keto
acid and PNP.
Here is our co-factor
PLP, covalently bound
to the lysine in the active side
of the enzyme via a Schiff's
base.
And here is our amino
acid starting material.
So in the first step, the lysine
that forms the Schiff base
with the co-factor is
going to be replaced
by the amine functionality
of the amino acid,
and it will form a new Schiff
base with the co-factor.
This starts with the amine group
attack on the pyridoxal carbon
to form a tetrahedral
intermediate.
And following an
additional proton transfer,
the lysine can be kicked off
to form the new Schiff base.
So far, we have started with
the Schiff's base corresponding
to the PLP bound to
the enzyme and we now
obtain a co-factor
forming a Schiff base
with the incoming amino acid 1.
So this portion of the mechanism
is called transamination,
because we're starting
with one amine
and we're forming
a different amine.
Now, let's take a look
at the alpha proton
attached to the
alpha carbon, which
we're going to highlight here.
This proton is now in between
two carbonyl-like groups.
Here is the carboxyl group and
here is the Schiff base group.
So it becomes acidic
enough that it
can be removed by an active
side base, for example
the lysine in the active site.
This will generate a
carbanium alpha carbon.
This carbanium can
only form because it
is resonance stabilized.
And indeed, the
PLP link system--
it's highly conjugated, and
it's a good electron sink.
For this carbanium,
we can write,
in fact, many different
resonance structures.
Let's take a look
at one of them.
This symbol denotes
resonance structures.
Notice in this structure
that the positive charge
on the pyrodine
nitrogen is now gone,
and highlights the fact that
this is a good electron sink.
And the ring now looks
more like a quinone.
That's why we call this
a quinoid structure,
or intermediate.
This quinoid structure shows us
a glimpse into how the reaction
will proceed, because the
alpha carbon now-- it's
doubly bonded to a
nitrogen, which anticipates
how this alpha carbon
will become a keto group
and a product of the reaction
will be an alpha keto acid.
What happens?
The quinoid structure
can be re-protonated,
but at a different place.
For example, on the aldehydic
carbon of pyridoxal.
To highlight that these facts--
these structures are in
fact resonance structures,
we're going to put
them in brackets.
So let's take a look
at what happened
in this past couple of steps.
So we had an alpha proton
that was fairly acidic,
it was able to be removed
by the active site lysine.
And then this proton came
back to a different position.
So all that's happened
in just a couple of steps
was a proton transfer.
Now, looking at
this intermediate,
we can see that in fact the
Schiff's base or the imine
of the PMP form of the co-factor
and the alpha keto acid
corresponding to amino acid 1.
So via a hydrolysis reaction,
these two can come apart.
So in the first step, an
activated water molecule
attacks alpha carbon, forming
a tetrahedral intermediate.
And one more proton
transfer and we're
going to kick off
the pyridoxamine form
of the co-factor.
And notice we obtain PMP
and the alpha keto acid
corresponding to
the amino acid 1.
This last step is, in fact,
just a hydrolysis reaction
of a Schiff base.
Now, let's take a look at
the second part of the PLP
transamination reaction.
The part one left us off
with formation of PMP.
So in this second part, PMP
will react with a new alpha keto
acid to regenerate PLP
and a new amino acid.
In fact, this part
of the mechanism--
it's the exact
reverse of part one.
Here is PMP and our
alpha keto acid.
In the first step,
we're going to form--
as we've gotten used so far--
to a new imine between the
keto group of alpha keto acid
and the amine group of PLP.
As usual, first we're going to
get a tetrahedral intermediate.
And one more proton
transfer, and we can kick off
the OH group to form the imine.
Now, this portion
of the reaction
is, in fact, imine
formation, which
is the reverse of the hydrolysis
step that we saw in part one.
Now, as you remember, there
is an active site lysine which
can act as a general base.
And it's going to de-protonate
one of these two protons
on the pyridoxal ring.
The reason that we can
form this carbanion
here is because
this negative charge
is delocalized throughout
the entire ring system.
And let's show one important
resonance structure.
Which is none other than
the quinoid structure
we saw before.
Just as before, the
protonated lysine
can now donate proton
on a different position.
For example, the alpha carbon
of the alpha keto acid.
As you can see
here, now the proton
is on the alpha position.
And now where this
starts to look more
like the Schiff's base
formed by an amino acid
with the PLP version
of the co-factor.
So from here on
onwards, we're just
going to substitute the PLP--
the amino acid
bound to the PLP--
with the active site lysine
in the transimination reaction
that we saw before.
So first, the lysine
can attack this carbon,
forming a tetrahedral
intermediate.
And then, following
some proton transfer,
we can kick off the amino acid
and generate the Schiff's base
corresponding to the PLP
co-factor bound to the enzyme.
So here we have
PLP, enzyme bound,
and the new amino acid 2.
We mentioned PLP is a
very versatile co-factor,
so let's take a look
what other reactions
besides transamination
can PLP catalyze.
One interesting reaction,
used especially by bacteria,
is a racemization.
This involves taking an L amino
acid, for example L alanine,
and converting it via a
PLP-catalyzed reaction to D
alanine.
This is an important
reaction for bacteria,
because they incorporate
the alanine into the cell
walls, which make it
very hard to recognize
by the immune system,
and makes it very hard
to digest by the host proteases.
Let's take a look at
a key intermediate
in the PLP-catalyzed reaction.
As before, L alanine
is going to react
with the PLP bound
to the enzyme,
and it's going to form an amine.
Here we're highlighting
the stereochemistry
of the alpha hydrogen. And
here is our active site lysine.
As we've seen before,
this alpha hydrogen
is acidic enough that it can
be removed by the lysine.
And it's going to form a
carbanion at this position.
Now, this carbanion,
as we've seen before,
is able to form because the
charge is, in fact, delocalized
through the entire system
of the pyridoxal ring.
So for this structure,
we can write
a number of resonance
structures, which we're not
going to mention here.
Now, this carbanion
can be re-protonated.
And here we had a--
the hydrogen was
pointing up on the top
of the plane of the page,
but we can re-protonate it
from the bottom, and that will
change the stereochemistry
of this carbon.
See if that re-protonation
happens from the bottom,
we will obtain the Schiff base
corresponding to the D alanine.
So by being able to
generate this carbanion
at the alpha position, the
PLP reaction and co-factor
allows the inversion
of the configuration
and the alpha carbon, converting
L alanine to D alanine.
Now, another interesting
reaction that requires PLP
is de-carboxylation.
Here we're looking at an amino
acid-- for example, glutamate.
In a PLP-catalyzed reaction,
you can lose this CO2 group
and form this molecule, which is
called gamma aminobutyric acid,
or GABA.
This is, in fact, a very
important neurotransmitter
and inhibitor, a
neurotransmitter
that is required in the brain.
Let's take a look how
this de-carboxylation
is catalyzed by PLP.
As always, have we seen
so far, the glutamate
will react with PLP bound in
the active site of the enzyme,
to form a Schiff base.
Here is the Schiff base.
Like that.
Now instead of de-protonating
at the alpha position,
the CO2 is activated to leave.
Because it will leave
behind the carbanion.
Such as that.
And as we've seen
before, a carbanion
formed at this position
can de-localize
throughout the entire
pyridoxal ring,
and therefore it stabilize
and it can exist long enough.
And we're not going
to draw, but there--
you can imagine, there are a
number of different resonance
structures.
Now, this carbanion-- it
gets protonated quickly
by a general acid, and will
generate this structure, which
is just a Schiff base
corresponding to gamma
aminobutyric acid with PLP.
And now, from here,
a transimination
where the active site
lysine will remove the PLP
and free up the GABA
products of the reaction.
In this video we talked about
PLP-catalyzed reactions.
PLP is the co-factor that
comes from vitamin B6.
Here's vitamin B6, what
we call pyridoxine,
which is the molecule that
we find in our vitamin pills.
Now, in the body,
pyridoxine formed
pyridoxal, which is activated
to form pyridoxal 5 phosphate,
or PLP.
And typically when
it reacts, PLP
is found as a Schiff's base
bound in the active site
via a lysine.
PLP is very important for
transamination reactions,
which are essential for the
metabolism of all amino acids.
We have seen the transamination
reaction where an amino acid
1 reacts with alpha keto acid 2
and the PLP catalyzed reaction
forms an alpha keto
acid 1 and amino acid 2,
essentially
transferring the group--
the amino group from the amino
acid to the alpha keto acid.
The reaction occurs
in two steps,
where first the amino acid is
transferred to PLP to form PMP.
Then PMP then
transfers this group--
the amino group-- back
to a alpha keto acid
to generate a new amino acid.
As we saw, the mechanism
of transamination
involves multiple steps.
The first step is a
transimination reaction
where the Schiff's base that's
formed between the active site
lysine and the PLP
becomes a Schiff's
base between the incoming
amino acid and PLP.
Next, we have a
proton transfer, which
is allowed by the
ability of the PLP ring
to stabilize a negative
charge, and move
the proton from
the alpha position
to somewhere on the PLP ring
via a quinoid structure.
And finally, that the
resulting Schiff base
is hydrolyzed to generate
PMP and an alpha keto acid.
In the second part
of the reaction,
PMP now reacts with alpha keto
acid to form a new Schiff base,
and then the proton transfer
happens in reverse, via, again,
a quinoid structure, to
generate the Schiff base
corresponding to the PLP
and the new amino acid 2.
Which, via a
transamination reaction
will generate amino acid 2
and the PLP enzyme bound.
Finally, we mentioned that
PLP is very versatile,
and it can catalyze
other reactions,
such as racemization,
for example,
switching the configuration
of the alpha carbon from L
alanine to D alanine, or
de-carboxylation, generating
alpha aminobutyric
acid, or GABA,
an important neurotransmitter
from glutamate.